well what do you think about uh khabib
is there something uh from just watching
him or is there something you can
imagine uh if he comes down to the gym
that you might learn from the way he
moves the way he approaches wrestling oh
absolutely he's one of the greatest
combat athletes of all time if you can't
learn for someone like that there's
something wrong with you so he
emphasizes control yes he does and he's
absolutely a master of exerting control
um
the amount of
grappling control he was able to put
over some of the most difficult people
in the world to control was truly
astounding he he beat people from every
cell he beat wrestlers he beat Jujitsu
players he beat kickboxers and he
controlled them all in more or less the
same way
um he has a very underrated bottom game
people think oh he's just about stifling
top control but people forget he was
taken down on several occasions and
ended up in bottom position and he
showed excellent guard work from bottom
he was able to get into submission holds
readily on opponents from bottom
position he's got an excellent bottom
game
um uh he people say oh he's just a
positional guy no he's not he's got
great submissions look at the
application of his triangle from both
top and bottom was Top Class he had a
sharp harm lock from uh bottom position
uh excellent Kimura if you look at
um his Kimura finishes and MMA they were
technically very very well Set uh
excellent braking mechanics
um he's a very very fine Grappler on
both submission grappling and MMA
grappling I think we'd probably learn a
ton from uh from moving around with him
is it possible to learn
something about him or about Hydra
Gracie or about Gordon by
watching them
or rolling around them for a little bit
so maybe hodger and and khabibas are
good examples
because they're able to do seemingly
very basic things
on everybody and dominate them with that
I think Gordon is as well but Gordon
seems to have more preference and range
of what he's able to do it's just it's
almost miraculous how much uh hodger can
do by just like the same exact thing and
everybody is that like uh is it possible
to understand why Hajj or khabib are so
good at very basic positions or do you
have to feel it or do you have to
or is it just something that's developed
over
I think I think for most people for the
vast majority of people it would have to
be explained to them
for a smaller group of people if they
felt it they could try to replicate it
and there are a few people who could
look at it and have enough knowledge and
say okay I can see what he's doing like
for example hodger could probably look
at video footage of could be great
playing and say okay I understand what
he's doing
um uh but the average person would
probably go over the hits